protein is important after the pitch
based training because there's a lot of
recent tweet loads I change your
direction it's critical that they get
those proteins in a repair afterwards we
use a creatine the benefits the football
player is gonna enhance our recovery
strategies a little bit or also help
with repeated sprints and that's of
explosive power and that's a real sort
helpful strategy for us as part of our
recovery protein it's not only gonna be
important for that repair but also for
growing new muscle if we've got players
there trying to grow and develop
physically especially in the academies
and with the younger players and even in
pre-season we'll have players losing
weight but we often increase the protein
there just to protect that lean mass and
make sure that they're not losing muscle
whilst they're losing body fat with the
amateur game I think they maybe don't
have the facilities to do everything
their professional needs but definitely
by improving their nutritional intake
immediately post performance or post
training is a hundred percent an easy
win it's a better recover and then in
turn enhance performance
[Music]